welcome to this video against yes yeah
read out for yourself come on what is he
going to do can I do what what about
what about something else okay I'm
adventurous doing for this defense iam
Alec Owens defends Knight f3 they
normally take nowadays only five when I
have played this opening a bit in the
1990s and back then I always played with
this year like c6 ha interesting let's
go see 6 I don't know about Bishop c4
probably probably that's possible okay
going to take know what this this is
this is not bad here actually that's a
decent setup for black it's a fairly
fairly solid and I have some ideas to
play against them to play against the e5
pawn Bishop f4 looks a bit strange to be
perfectly honest if I take it and play
Queen to e5 how is he protecting his
pawn rook e1 is kind of covered yeah so
I'm winning the big Center pony yeah
that's the big idea of the eloquence
defense lure the pound forward then win
it and sometimes it does work this is
one of the rare cases okay going to take
the poor Nia with the Queen
okay so why not I'm going to improve my
night position to f6 with tempo that
cannot be a bad idea Bishop t6 with the
temple yeah that looks good and now I
would like to do I want to trade Queen
sir probably with the pawn Queen to h5
maybe now come on that's it sir that's a
simple simple way to play here either
trades or goes back to g2 Queen on e5
was always in like rook e1 those kind of
moves so don't mind to move the Queen
prophylactically let's say yeah what
rook I don't know let's take the a frog
not clear the only thing that I don't
like here is opposite colored bishops of
course this this could be an issue so
I'm going to go here that's good I think
intending to just snap of the night to
make sure that we don't get opposite
colored bishops or let's say we have
them but to make sure that when my
bishop is leaving the board this is some
not anymore the case I'm also
threatening to take over on the D file
here a little bit with Queen age five
and rook the eighth looking at the d1
rook yeah night before scientistic you
wanna so okay he took that one and he's
in the spin so i will get his nitrated
if i can actually damage his pawn
structure that would be really nice
then my night would even be a very
decent term minor piece okay Queen
somewhere I here maybe oops no 94 I can
take see form so i can i can go here
quite resigned yeah i will win another
pawn there on c3 and route d 2 and so on
yeah it was was kind of interesting it
was some typical play in the l a-- coins
things takes yeah here he has to I think
here he has to start think about what to
do about the e5 pawn so that he can yeah
like that he can do that he save them I
have some ideas to attack the porn i
mean this is this is kind of clear and
Bishop f4 was was giving the pawn away
but he can go here of course like this
this is how it might unfold night will
come here and attacking e5 yet again
maybe 92 to f3 or so this is the the way
it probably should them should play out
if it's not playing Bishop f4 yeah here
this is just the big porn turn yeah the
only thing is that i should use all
these tempe yeah queen age five is
probably not the best move I don't know
maybe you should trade I'm not sure the
second thing is instructive thing is
maybe here that we want to get rid of
this this Bishop even even this I would
probably just take that and and play
this kind of position yeah with the
extra porn and now we have night against
bishop in a pretty static position so
why not not sure about the precise move
on here maybe I should on can also go
here yeah well it doesn't matter so much
the single move here it's a pawn and he
has no particular play for it and no
opposite color
okay well thanks for watching